I mean  why though yeah  but why though  very weird yeah  yeah so it's I mean what how much time  do you have yeah yeah like he was  playing on inclement basically oh okay  yeah but okay you just go King C6 King  B5 and you walk the king in now I just  don't understand okay I mean one  explanation is uh the match is until  that draw they were losing for about  half so there's absolutely nothing  riding on this so he wasn't very  emotionally invested maybe but still  like what it's  Christian is a very strong player it's a  kind of a difficult decision for me to  process because like it's not like  you're running very many risks no even  if you have 30 seconds for a move here  it's not like you're going to lose this  game  yeah that's confusing but okay it really  uh